[Music]
so I recently read about this polish guy
who was blind for two decades that
miraculously got his vision back what
getting hit by a car
what like movie [ __ ] hit back hard
because you couldn't see jaywalking I
been like all these black people are
listening to this now and they're just
walking into the freeway oh they're like
bro smack me with something smack or
something that's a good question but so
he was saying that he fell on the car
bonnet I don't know what a car bonnet is
but the heard of a car maybe is this a
hero hood I know in England it's called
the okay Casey yo you weird ass Brits so
the hood of a car is called a bonnet a
bonnet and in the booth it no it's
called the bomb no no the back of the
car is called the bomb yeah I've been to
Britain I know this year I mean I've
been there too and the biscuit is the
roof oh the tyres are the tea bags
you said trumpet just don't let's not
glaze over that right yeah the only have
trumpets over there Geo that's right
learn something new every day don't get
confused this happened in Poland hit his
head and then he slipped and then fell
on the road so then he was taken to the
hospital real quick can I just say I
realized this is trombone motion and
this is trumpet okay go on
I just needed to make okay because as
soon as I did this for my joke I was
like that's not a trumpet and then I
sold it better than was a trombone yeah
yeah you're right we go on so so then
when he went to the hospital in two
weeks
his
vision started getting like better like
you can actually Bob Casey walk to the
car hit him yes while being in the
hospital so he didn't even sue the car
no he should be paying the car thank you
it's a [ __ ] was he born blonde so the
thing is he had been blind for the last
two decades and so he was blinded at a
young age after having a big hit by a
car after having a bad allergic reaction
so it left him completely blind in his
left eye and he could only vaguely
recognize shapes and lights and his
right human being equivalent of like
smacking your xbox it's not working yeah
oh yeah there it is so it [ __ ]
triggered something in his brain like
the impact just did something you just
needed someone to go like this to his
eyes as goal Oh like a blank cartridge
yeah it's blowing out a bit a little bit
all right
okay well so this man they are they're
speculating that it could probably be
because of the large doses of
anticoagulant medicine that was mixed
with other drugs would've helped him but
the thing is that this dude after he got
his eyesight and stuff
he was just like okay I'm done with the
hospital and so he's not really
participating in any more tests
to really find out what happened here
it's like I could see I don't care right
after this whole thing happened gets hit
by a car he's lying again I haven't seen
[ __ ] in 20 years and I discover porn I'm
jacking off like a [ __ ] I'm like
I'm not going back to the hospital
I'm busy jacking off but it says porn
now oh [ __ ] it's late don't want to look
at a waterfall or something that's the
squirt squirt point oh I see
oh those dogs getting it yes sir then
have talent on those girls what's more
attractive visit to lend the distance or
the width of the spray the amount the
amount oh [ __ ]
definitely impressive I've never been a
fan
the squirting porn though no I mean but
when you don't judge okay Wow I'm just
saying
different strokes man all right strokes
for different jokes this is the man his
name is Jan Janos janitor yeah cuz Tim
is the polish sex yeah it was that I
don't trust my eyeballs in my
pronunciations I'm like your human being
oh he can try it Bob she read that all
wrong
okay so Bob what he looks like oh my god
you dinner he was driving that car look
at the car he got hit on I don't know oh
he's sitting they published look all
[ __ ] up right there that's how he
loves that's what it looks like when
he's buns Tim gets those knives do i oh
yeah you do yeah through people you got
you could see two people that one was a
goldfish superpower yeah so so then
after this whole thing he has now he's
now able to live an independent life and
he started to work as a security guard
at that Hospital oh so they're saying
they're just like so we don't know if he
specifically asked for a job there or
just started doing it he just started
doing it he [ __ ] hooked up with a
security guard outfit and he started
work are they having trouble reaching
him then he's right there no it's not
that they're having trouble reaching
that he will no longer participate
what if he's so good at being blind that
he's still blind and he's like oh now I
can see all of a sudden and he's just
like he's like you know you just heard
that they needed security guys I'm good
I'm good no all of a sudden yeah you
know for me like out of all my senses if
I would lose sight that's the one that I
can't live without like I really can't
that's pretty rough remember though when
we went to the the dinner and
everything's pitch black and like just
trying to have dinner in darkness I'm
like I need my eyes I can't do this that
was such an everybody's potatoes or
potato damn y'all went I wanna I want to
do that how was it I would say it's not
an intimate event between a couple I
would say I would recommend go there in
a [ __ ] flock of people yeah we did
and then there was a couple nearby and
then because we were yelling since we
could see each other we're just like
like it got louder and louder with our
group and then we at one point we're
like oh [ __ ] we're yelling so then we
thought we settled down and then Joe
Piketty move you're like is anyone else
here with us and then they're like this
couple behind it yeah cuz the whole room
is eating together right so like if no
one's talking either
oh god then you can hear this person do
you feel like it heightened you're
tasting though that's the point but cuz
you guys are so just anxious well you
start paying attention to things you
don't want to so like what I need is a
restroom and I grab the chair I might
with these are Chinese restaurant chairs
when the plate come and you touch it on
my way these are those Chinese
restaurant soup spoons so it's supposed
to be an upscale place but as I started
touching things I'm like wait this is
the Chinese restaurant with like
different French food or cellulite you
know of either McDonald's napkins yeah
yeah yeah start feeling everything like
light like someone was wearing an Apple
watch and then the green light under
that like you know is detecting our
heartbeat or whatever that would shine
and then it's like very very that's like
your eyes get thirsty for life right
it's like trying to make sense of [ __ ]
or it would outline a shape like your
mind would play tricks on you
it would silhouette a human being or
like a plate or whatever that
Tai I want to go I don't know it was
kind of wack for me like they should do
a sound like we have to wear
noise-cancelling headphones and you go
to a restaurant
screaming Sui it's the same [ __ ] I'm
like I don't want one of these things I
don't like this does not help me eat
this does not help me talk to friends
going well where they plug your nose and
you just eat the food oh [ __ ] the same
establishment with different rooms for
different senses that are oh yeah you go
into one and there's a tongue condoms
yeah won't go somewhere go to restaurant
or they numb your hands so you don't
even or you don't you don't know if you
have this yeah you sit on them for two
hours if we walk into the restaurant and
it's like you can't you don't know if
you're [ __ ] oh your whole arm is no
you're just like Charlotte laughing
that's funny
oh there's a game playing soccer forever
it's called it's on the Xbox and that's
what the the human is like it's guiding
by the chest and you have to like do
[ __ ] weird it's a really fun game I
forget what it's called but anyway yeah
that's the one scent that I can't I
can't live without that's pretty
important yeah yeah I mean I guess if I
was sick you Lewin yeah cuz you could
still do a lot of [ __ ] if you can see
when you can't hear them you can still
go travel you can use pretty independent
you can't listen to music no more you
can't talk to people
the vibrations you we can still text you
know we can text people or whatever yeah
yeah I'm with you I think seeing is mine
yeah sure yeah cuz hearing I don't need
to hear music I could remember music and
[ __ ] like it like I can hear music right
now you and I can yell at everyone and
not hear what they're talking about and
I can read lips I'll be like but yeah I
imagine 20 years without this without
sight and then all of a sudden getting
your sight man I would feel like the
luckiest person in the planet morality
I'm gonna play the lottery that's
probably what he does when I go back to
the hospital he doesn't want them to
[ __ ] it up like imagine they're like hey
let's let's see what did this to you
like yeah they're like okay take this
ass but he's like [ __ ] that's what made
me blind
and you mother money I'm so careful
without you cuz you never know and did
he think the guy that ran him over
man he looks like he makes really good
hot dogs though huh Polish man you know
man would you feel some sort of
responsibility they would like to want
to get this tested to see maybe this
could help other point I would but I'm
with him where I'm like I don't want
them to [ __ ] it up like there's probably
that screw or whatever that they put it
back in I'm like oh [ __ ] it's gone if I
was the guy that ran them over I'd start
a business you're the black didn't I
just have a line of blind people like on
the street on my ratty [ __ ] you
roll down the window no you just stand
on the red X yeah yeah no a little bit
back out wrong oh he [ __ ] hates and
flies and hits the [ __ ] hood and I'm
like cheered [ __ ] shake can you see yet
and he's like no and I okay let me back
up over yet Squidward's face and then he
kept trying to make him ugly because he
was too beautiful
Oh keep coming out as that [ __ ]
handsome yeah like the more getting more
and more handsome I'll have a tally mark
like you know those World War 2 [ __ ]
fighter planes when they kill one they
they make a mark so every change yeah
it's like I'll be dope but teardrop
these are in satisfied customers yeah
like that one took a Buick that one took
a Chevy he didn't respond well to Ford
so we had to go Acura oh we got a
dependent yeah we're gonna have a whole
junkyard with the car that guy god we
hit with everything then all of a sudden
dodge Rams will work what's the one
never hey he died but he was able to see
right before he died oh he said wow I
know you're a handsome guy and I said
all things
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]